(audience applauding)
- I love this. You look so-
- Thank you!
- You look so like, it's
like rock and roll and cute.
I don't know how you're
pulling all of it off.
- Yeah. It's like you're
describing yourself
and I wanted to dress as your essence.
(Kelly laughing)
- I am not describing myself.
(Alison laughing)
- You do not catch me at Target.
So is it true that you
were once in a cover band?
- Yes.
- Here's how I know!
No joke, my hair guy
actually has seen you.
- Yes, Robert!
- Yes, Robert, yes!
He's like, I've actually seen her.
I was like, wait, what?
- [Alison] Oh my god.
- I didn't know this.
- So funny. Yes. I've had a
cover band called The Girls.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- For a few years.
Actually my friend Danny Pudi,
who I worked with on Community.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Alison] And he is in this movie,
Somebody I Used to Know, with me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Introduced me to his
friends, had this band,
Jones Street Station,
and they were like, "Why don't
you come and open for us?"
It all kind of came
together very organically.
So me and my two best
girlfriends, Julianna Guill
and Cyrina Fiallo, we're all actresses
and it became this great hobby
where we were like, you know,
so seldom in our lives do we have control
over our creative output as actresses.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- You're kind of waiting for a job.
- Musicians suffer from
this as well. Yes. Yeah.
- So it gave us, you know,
something creative that
we could all do together
and we would each take
turns choosing a fun song
and it was everything from Wheezer
to Bruce Springsteen to Queen
and then we would break it
down into three part harmonies
and sing and the band Joan
Street Station would back us.
We were like their opening act.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- It was great.
- So wait, so how young were you
when you started performing?
- Gosh, you know, for a
long time I've thought,
oh the first time I
performed is when I was like
six years old doing community theater.
- Yeah.
- And then literally two days ago,
my sister texted me a picture,
reminding me that she and I did this
baby, sort of, workout video when we were-
- [Kelly] No way!
- [Alison] I think she was,
I was like two years old.
That's my sister on the cover of the box.
That's me.
- [Kelly] This is you in
like a baby workout video?
- Little leg warmers.
Yes. So it's called Baby
Dynamics and basically,
(Kelly laughing)
it was like sort of early, you
know, hand eye coordination.
- You were Jane Fonda
before she was! Yeah!
- I know. The people didn't even know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I think they meant well
and it's all about like
teaching your kids,
kind of like that early
connection to their body.
- Yeah.
- But I have to say, watching it.
All the props that they would use,
it would be like, and then
you'll go to the balance beam
and have your child walk
across the low beam.
That's what my sister does in the video.
Or you'll throw these bean bags into like,
a large tire swing that's painted purple.
I'm like what parent at home,
renting these VHS's in
the eighties was like,
cool, I'll just-
- Go out out back with my balance beam.
- [Alison] Yeah.
- Yeah. Nobody had a balance
beam in their backyard
unless you were a gymnast.
- Yeah, exactly.
- They were like, money.
(Alison laughing)
- Then you're gonna be
spelunking in the next video,
(Kelly laughing)
we're gonna repel you.
(Alison laughing)
- These are average things
you can find in your home
just grab them.
- [Alison] Yeah, yeah. You
could make this with a few pans.
- I love that you didn't
even know that though.
And then your sister got-
- I forgot. My sister's like
I always forget too because
we were just so, so little.
- Yeah, I love that. All right.
(audience cheering)
So the new movie is called
Somebody I Used to Know
and we actually just had
your co-star Jay Ellis on.
Love him!
- Oh my God. He is the best.
- He is so fun.
And he said that you
wrote it with your husband
during COVID?
- That's right, yeah.
- So you were productive.
Most people just made sourdough
bread or something. Yeah.
- We did that too. We did.
We had a pasta phase, a pizza phase.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- A wine phase.
- The whole phase.
- Yeah.
- The whole.
- But Dave and I were actually
talking a lot about this idea
right before the pandemic started.
So it was actually kind of like,
a great opportunity to write that.
And then we got to spend the pandemic
watching a ton of rom-coms.
You know, we really wanted
to tap into all our favorite
nineties rom-coms.
- Then you had you to tap way back.
'Cause they don't really
make a lot of them anymore.
- We've been tapping 'em back.
They're coming back.
- [Kelly] I know!
- There's a lot of good ones recently.
- I'm watching every single one of them
to promote them being made.
(Alison laughing)
Is it hard to work that close?
Like you're at home with your husband,
you're doing, you know, work life stuff.
- Sure.
- And then you're doing personal stuff.
Is that hard? Is that overwhelming?
- No, I think, um.
- [Kelly] Are you all good at
boundaries and stuff like that?
- We're pretty good at boundaries.
- That means no, what you just said!
- The slowness, it did imply no.
I was more thinking, I
guess we're just okay
being around each other a lot. Which is-
- [Kelly] Your best friends. That's cool.
- Exactly.
I think the boundaries
probably come more into play,
right, when we're on set.
So this is a romantic
movie and Dave, my husband,
is not in it.
- I know I talked about this with Jay.
- Jay plays my love interest in the movie.
- Yes.
- So wait, I have this clip.
Wait, your husband directed it.
So here's what your co-star Jay had to say
about that special experience.
(swiping sound)
They're married and like
he's the director, right?
- [Jay] Yeah.
- So like you and Alison
have like, intimate scenes.
(Jay laughing)
- We were probably about
this far away from each other
and Dave's like, Jay, you
could scoot a little closer.
And I was like, huh?
- Huh?
- Say what, you want me to do what?
(Kelly laughing)
You scoot closer. Okay.
- Fine.
(Kelly laughing)
It's like-
- Jay. That was like, you
barely even moved man.
Like can you scoot closer?
And I'm like, are you sure?
There's just, it feels like
we're really close Dave.
- [Kelly] Feels like room for the.
- To your wife.
It feels like I'm really
close to your wife, man.
(swiping sound)
- I mean, you're actors. I get it.
That's what the answer is.
But like, is it not awkward at all
for your husband to be filming you
while you're in like a intimate
scene with another dude?
(audience laughing)
- When you say it like that?
- [Kelly] I know!
- It seems like I should say yes,
but I actually don't think so.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I think it's so funny.
- You're acting.
- I've never talked about it with Jay
and I always think it must
be weirdest for that person.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Who's in the scene with me.
- 'Cause Dave and I, I
think also it takes so much
to get a movie made
that our minds are like,
this scene, we wrote it a
year ago, we're making it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Here's how we envisioned it.
- You're thinking big pictures.
- Yeah. And Jay's like,
your husband's like,
sitting 50 feet away, like
scrutinizing every move.
And I'm like, what if I
linger longer near your mouth?
And Jay's like, ahhh, Dave?
(Kelly laughing)
What did you, and Dave's like linger.
- Oh my gosh. This is,
you have the most like,
comfortable relationship ever.
I love it. How did y'all meet?
- Dave and I? Well we met at Mardi Gras,
which is its own story. You can Google it.
- Beads were involved, possibly.
- It's just, yes.
But we realized, you know, we
met through a mutual friend.
My friend Jules, who was
in the cover band with me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we realized after we'd
been dating for quite a while,
we were kind of trying
to do the math on like,
when you're introduced
from a mutual friend,
you're kinda like, we must
have met before, like.
- [Kelly] Been at the
same place or something.
- Right. Like this friend of mine
used to have an annual
Halloween party every year.
It was like a big thing
and everyone she knew
came to it every year.
So, that was us kind of sitting
and going like, I was like,
"Well you must have been at
Jules's Halloween party."
And he's like, "Definitely,
I went many times."
So now we start playing like,
Halloween costume roulette.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, do you remember
when we were, yeah,
synchronized swimmers? No.
I'm like, how about when
we were California raisins,
nobody knew what we were and
everybody spent the night
putting out different guesses
for what the costume was.
But, to show people, to demonstrate,
we spent the whole night
gathering in little groups
and singing 'I Heard it
Through the Grapevine'
and he was like, "Yes I do remember that.
I was at the party dressed as,
me and my friend were Mario and Luigi."
And I was like, "I don't
remember that at all."
(Kelly laughing)
Don't do this to me.
- You were not memorable.
- So then we go back, I
find on an old computer,
a video from that night of
me and three of my friends
singing 'I Heard it
Through the Grapevine.'
Yeah. And it's tight on us.
- [Kelly] No way he's in it.
- Who is in the back corner of the video
but Mario and Luigi.
(audience laughing)
The cutest Mario I've ever seen.
- That is amazing
though. Isn't that weird?
That's a movie!